en efecto te recojo la palabra abbas
dijo fin a la ocupación en pro de una
paz un estado palestino con capital
jerusalén este y siguió apelando a los
refugiados a lo que viven los palestinos
respecto a las leyes y políticas de
israel y eso es lo que siguió
básicamente en todo su discurso el
presidente estadounidense joe biden que
apoyó a la solución de dos estados es
una solución de la que ha hablado todo
su viaje sin concretar un plan como los
anteriores presidentes del país y él
reconoció que el terreno no está listo
para un así no quería dar de esta
esperanza al pueblo palestino porque
apeló bastante e hizo varias menciones a
lo que están sufriendo en cuanto a la
calidad de vida del pueblo palestino
pero aún así dijo que ese sufrimiento
está presente y que había que
comprometerse a una paz una paz de la
que abás extendió la mano a las
autoridades israelíes y en este sentido
en cuanto a una paz se esperaba
muchísimo que el presidente
estadounidense mencionara el asesinato
de la periodista irina bucle lo hizo
errando en su nombre pero aún así que
resaltó su legado y fue bastante
prometido en luchar por que haya una
investigación que esclarezca su muerte
en el campo de refugiados de yenín por
una bala una bala que las ongs incluso
naciones unidas han denunciado que
pertenecía a las fuerzas israelíes claro
yanira ahora hablemos de la próxima
parada en esta gira por medio oriente
del presidente estadounidense que como
lo estábamos hablando es arabia saudita
va a ir a este reino también en medio de
una polémica también por las palabras
que tuvo digamos el presidente yo bailé
en contra el reino saudita por el
asesinato del periodista llamado joe y
en el consulado de estambul todo es
mucho más además históricamente se
vuelve a digamos se reabre este espacio
aéreo entre riad e israel en vuelos
directos que lo va a inaugurar digamos
esta ruta el presidente yo baiden yanira
esa es la primera medida exitosa en
cuanto a la visita de biden por medio
oriente es lo que pretendía unir israel
con arabia saudita y con esta apertura
del espacio aéreo aéreo a todos los
vuelos desde y hacia israel lo ha
conseguido ha sido un primer éxito
aunque no era exclusivo en 2020 una era
la aerolínea israelí el al ya había
efectuado un vuelo hacia emiratos que le
había permitido así que bueno es una
excepción que vaivén ha aplaudido como
una histórica decisión aún así aunque
esta es la antesala de ese viajar a
arabia saudita que como dices es
cuestionado por el asesinato de yamaha
socks y que la cia ha apuntado que que
la responsabilidad la tiene el reino
saudita aún así no se espera que vaya a
haber un avance de las relaciones como
así sucede con emiratos obrar en o
marruecos si es cierto que este es un
paso pero por ejemplo en cuanto al aéreo
todavía falta una relación directa entre
israel y arabia saudita que se espera
vamos a ver entonces de qué ocurre tras
esta visita el presidente byte en arabia
saudita yanira como siempre un gusto
conversar con usted